yeah we had a hash brown shoulders in
japan for a couple of days the potatoes
yeah because of the potatoes but it was
it was so bad to the point we couldn't
even get hash browns wait wait why was
there potato shortage uh japan doesn't
import potatoes
uh oh yeah okay so they only accept like
their potatoes
because they believe that they're so we
had a potato shortage we had a potato
shortage was the the french fries wasn't
was in it because they couldn't get the
stock like the other imports maybe i'm
pretty sure japan doesn't import the
majority of that
whatever the issue was it was obvious as
a result the pandemic and then for i
think it was only for like two or three
days because they they had this a few
years ago with um potato chips in japan
or crisps um they yeah they didn't have
any potatoes because there was a i think
there was a really bad season and they
refused to import potatoes because they
saw them as lower quality yeah yeah um
you know it's a lot of [ __ ] potatoes
potato let's be honest yeah they're not
gonna lie like uh yeah so they didn't
have any pizza potato chips and people
were really angry
big salad of course like they
do import yeah fries are processed in
the us and canada before being cheap oh
really they are maybe it's just uh maybe
potato chips then like shipping
disruptions in on vancouver side so you
can go all right maybe it's just for
potato chips then japan is like or like
maybe cal b is like no we don't use
japanese yeah we only use japanese
company thing not uh like yeah i think
that makes sense really and japan japan
does have this massive culture around
that you know vegetables and ingredients
and where it comes from and it being
high quality and it needs to come from
ex prefecture otherwise it's not right
and then you taste it and you're like
this is just a very good version of x
thing that i normally eat anyway for 10
i want to do a test where we get the
same vegetables that's an after dark
stream yeah from different prefectures
and see if we can figure it out all like
the expensive versus cheap fruits yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah because because i
will say like you know there's some
fruits where i've had like you you have
like japanese strawberries for example
and i don't think i've had a bat
i don't think i've ever had a bad
japanese strawberry but like it's it's
more of like
consistency huh you had bad strawberries
in the uk you know there are some
strawberries where you have and it's
like it's just not that sweet it's like
sometimes it's
a bit sour you know it's still
strawberry but every every every time i
buy a packet of strawberries from japan
it's like three four times the cost but
every [ __ ] strawberry it's like the
sweetest strawberry you would get from a
uk supermarket this is the non-branded
this is also sad that they probably
waste a lot more food as well i probably
just throw away the ones that don't meet
the quality standards i don't think it's
that i think it's just the quality of
like cultivation is just like incredibly
high okay because like i remember i
think i saw this like documentary about
uh like melons yeah i saw that one on
youtube yeah the melons one is like the
[ __ ] process of that is like insane
like this guy this dude in like his 50s
is like taking better care of this melon
than some parents do their children like
i was taking better care of the
mountains than i was myself yeah right
so it's it's just nuts to think that
like yeah it's like okay yeah now that i
see the process i can't understand why
it's a little more expensive and way
tastier but can it justify me paying
three hundred dollars
i just wish there was a cheaper option
you know yeah
like because i would be fine with it if
there was a natural option that you know
um rivaled the price of the of the the
same ingredients i would play in like
the uk or i think that's the problem
like i remember i used to eat so much
fruit in australia just because like an
apple was like less than a dollar yeah
and it's just [ __ ] easy to pick up
and it was cheap and it all tasted good
but like
in japan like
the cheapest apple you can get is like
300 yen or something yeah and it's just
like i can't justify me
spending 30 dollars for an apple some
sometimes you want that high quality
experience i get that with every bite
that you take but sometimes you just
want to eat a shitload of one thing and
not have to feel guilty afterwards for
spending a lot of money if you eat steak
every day sometimes you want a hamburger
you know like it's just it's just how it
is i know japan doesn't grow be honest
does it i don't think it can they can
grow here right
bananas
i don't think it's hot enough i think
bananas are all imported from like
philippines yeah i love the banana gacha
you know where you're like the banana
gadget you crack open a banana and
you're like i have no idea if this
banana is going to be like [ __ ] or good
right you know what i mean can grow
bananas
oh that makes sense oh okay yeah you
just never know if a banana is going to
taste like the perfect banana right what
is the perfect banana
it depends right some people like are
really like brown and like something oh
i hate it brown no i don't like it brown
you know you want it to be sometimes you
bite into a banana and it's like
fighting back sometimes it's like kind
of tough
you're like what the [ __ ] happened it's
got some give yeah i would prefer banana
be
too ripe than too brown to me like i i i
too ripe it's like rock solid i prefer
when it's like just just like a tiny bit
of firmness just like a tiny bit of
firmness still there that's that's like
my perfect banana it's not like it's you
know it's not completely green but it's
not like it's it's just just turned
completely yellow that's like to me
that's like my perfect banana yeah i
don't like the green ones but sometimes
even you do get like a non-green one and
it it still is like rock solid or
something yeah it's like yeah i don't
even know what's what's what i'm gonna
get with these bananas and frankly i
quite enjoyed that i quite enjoyed that
maybe i'll get that god tear banana that
is just like really smooth
kind of a little bit sweet you're like
oh this is just the perfect banana why
would you ever play a garcia game when
just you can just but
you just never know you never know if
you're gonna get a good banana that's
what i love about bananas it's so sad
though because i really miss eating like
a lot of fruits um but just i just again
i i can't justify myself it's like
banana is actually one of the cheaper
fruits yeah in japan like yeah because
it's important
yeah yeah yeah like you know maybe like
three bucks for like maybe five or six
years are you like i eat like three
bananas a day because it's just the one
fruit i get every coffee
i actually do you know what i realized
the other day i don't know why i really
really like bananas
i think it's because they're like
pre-portioned okay yeah they are like
the products
they are like we love as humans we love
portioned food we love it when something
tells us this is how much you're eating
yeah and the banana is the perfect one i
really really love bananas i like eat
them every day i'm a jojo fan as well
but but i gobble them up but for some
reason i hate banana flavored stuff like
no i don't i don't know why one is i
don't like banana flavored sweets i just
there's just something depends for me
well you know because the banana
flavored stuff is from uh
a variety of banana that is that we
don't use anymore it's like extinct oh
really yeah because it's it's the it's
the the artificial but it has this like
aftertaste that tastes so artificial
that it just really puts me off so it's
like i think it was i don't know if it's
if the one we use right now is the
cavendish banana or the one before i
know there's a bunch of youtube videos
about this yeah there's the one before
apparently is much sweeter much better
flavor but like a plague wiped out that
that like that uh that type of banana so
they had to grow another one that's more
resistant problem is that it apparently
doesn't taste as good yeah so the
original banana sweetened flavor stuff
that you taste and stuff especially that
original banana flavor yeah supposedly
right i don't know if it's true i i
don't mind the artificial i really like
the artificial banana flavor more than
the like real banana flavor so i feel
like i've been robbed
you like the artificial banana flavoured
more yeah why because i feel like i'm
missing out on the og banana experience
you know i feel like i can't relate to
this
mythical banana as a monkey
my ancestors had it good they had the og
banana you know the sweeter banana the
better banana have you have your sisters
or eaten good
stink bananas later is
actually became more popular than
bananas because nobody ever eaten my god
the mythical banana yeah because that's
that's what that's what i taste when i
taste banana flavored stuff it doesn't
taste like real banana to me that's
because you your concept of real banana
is the only like one that we grow that
is your real banana flavor is that all
what a real banana is that's one variant
of banana there's so many bananas you're
all taste different you're eating a real
banana or actually like mine you are but
there are more flavors than the flavor
you know
no i i know that
resources actually my favorite banana
actually is
my favorite banana is actually southeast
asian bananas i don't
like like it's like okay i don't know if
i love east asia i don't know but i'm
saying southeast asian because i've only
had it thailand huh not european
european bananas are the same [ __ ]
bananas that we import right but
southeast asian bananas are like they're
funny out of context
i can't wait for the banana edit of this
jojo fans arguing about dicks
in the comment section of this clip
bananerologist here uh
so
no because like in thailand you can get
like these really small bananas that are
like hard oh the finger bananas the
finger bananas yeah i like those which
is like what you what is what they taste
like if you take you take one of the
full bananas we are used to and just
pack all that flavor in half the size
it's getting the big banana photoshop
yeah
like i'm like [ __ ] addicted to those
bananas because like my my dad comes in
with a pack of like they don't even sell
them in like you know packeted um
they don't sell them in like packeted
bunches you just take like you just buy
them by the bunch and like you buy like
a bunch of like 10 or 20 and i swear i
can get through like 10 in a day like i
i like i like eat one and like i'm like
[ __ ] seeing horrible yeah yeah
exactly potassium overflow the [ __ ]
ape
the [ __ ] uh the [ __ ] eight brain
just takes over i'm just like [ __ ]
just give me ten right now
do you think that all apples have the
same taste no i don't well then i think
that's the same thing with bananas
except we just don't start this
conversation
we don't have the other bananas
right
where have you had the other banana i
haven't i want to no one's had it
it exists it's literally a myth it's
like you know we just established all of
the apple flavors are really distinctly
different right yeah yeah it tastes very
very different yes that's what we've
missed out on with bananas
you're speaking about a mythical banana
about this artificial tasting i'm not
[Applause]
you've never tasted it before so how can
you say that this tastes like this
mythical banana you're actually talking
about your ass right i want to try this
banana that i know is gonna taste
different what if it doesn't exist what
if it's just it doesn't completely
artificially
have they perfectly replicated that
flavor in half oh
how do we know because what are the
units back then you know science was
just a guessing game back then exactly
so how did we know that this typical
banana tastes the same as the artificial
slavery you can just you know uh you
know
speculate based on our app i can
speculate what a [ __ ] dinosaur tastes
like i'm gonna taste the [ __ ]
dinosaur i bet it tastes like a bear
like if someone came out with like a
[ __ ] dinosaur flavored lollipop or
steak or something i'd be like cool this
is completely [ __ ] because no one's
ever tasted the [ __ ] dinosaur we
never got to taste the dinosaur i wish
we could have tasted what down it like a
t-rex probably tasted great
we'd be arguing about that t-rex would
be gamey as [ __ ] are you [ __ ] kidding
me
what is that what would be the tastiest
dinosaur like the the thomas let's start
that tommy
what's the [ __ ] long neck shits
that's uh
the [ __ ]
the brachiosaurus brachiosaurus i bet
they tasted delicious you know we missed
out on all these foods and stuff you
know that we could have had trash taste
we've literally run out of food we can
argue about so
let's argue about
let's argue about food that doesn't
exist anymore speculating
i can just wake up in a cold sweat and
wonder what bananas we've missed out on
them that does happen that doesn't
i just don't know if it's ever crossed
your mind what the word artificial means
it means it doesn't exist because
they're speculating the bananas we've
lost
what if the bananas we lost just taste
like absolutely goblins i i was i'd be
able to sleep in it probably does
because there are other if there's like
they if they're extinct because they
were little [ __ ] like gordon ramsay
didn't like them they were going extinct
because the plague wiped them out
it's not the play
we got rid of these shitty bananas
we'll give you these other ones you can
imagine what it tastes like [ __ ]
argument would you ever want to taste a
dodo cause man if
they went extinct because they got over
hunted so i'm just like damn how good do
these [ __ ] birds take over hunted for
what purpose were they whether they have
like a beach that was special or
something uh no because
it tasted good do you know why ashley i
can google it for you google it i'm
going to speculate isn't it because they
were just [ __ ] weak animals
like
kind of like i i've heard that dodos
were just like they were just [ __ ]
stupid yeah yeah they're like really
dumb and they were like if there was a
predator that came up to it they
wouldn't even know it was a predator
like that's how dumb they were
supposedly one of the reasons is because
look i've seen ice age
i know exactly what happened natural
habitat was almost completely destroyed
by after people started settling on
mauritius wow
this is why you know sometimes i watch
those youtube videos where it's like the
uh
like the animal like there's a tiger
eating a [ __ ] deer yeah yeah you know
and you go in the comments like oh my
god i wish i could have helped the deer
and it's like what stopped nature like
what do you mean would you like what are
you gonna do
like i hate these comments or they're
like i wish i could have helped that
poor animal like this is literally
nature like just let it do its thing we
would be in this position if it weren't
for where we are right now yeah we're a
plague all right yeah yeah yeah we
should probably not we're the problem
we're the virus when you're asking a
lion not to like eat it's prey it's like
no that's what a lion does that's like
the whole point that's why
that's why everything exists it's like
let it do it like don't intervene what
are you gonna do just like go to line be
like just stop
yeah and be like yeah you're right
veganism that's an option but i think i
think david attenborough spoke about
this one time as well and he was like
someone asked him in an interview there
do you ever feel like sorry for the
animals that like i think this is one
with like the birds were falling down
and yeah and stuff something and he was
like no you know it's just unfortunate
this is life that's that's nature it's
not our place to intervene yeah to get
involved and say who can do what until
obviously we burn down all the forests
and literally
that is kind of on us we should probably
intervene as little as possible yeah
yeah
i don't know
i hate those though
what is it you want to say ashley there
was an animal that was literally eaten
to death though i think it was the giant
tortoise most most worst animals are
eating yeah that's enough
fun
the whole species together okay that's
on us
what animal was that i think it was a
giant tortoise how the [ __ ] do you eat
that
[Music]
what
what's [ __ ] wrong with that well
apparently they make turtle soup and
stuff that's like yeah i don't know
just i just find it just the image of
just a guy looking at a giant towards me
like delicious
i don't know it really was delicious
i don't i don't want to i don't know
we've eaten a lot weirder things that is
true
if if there's something that's breathing
i'm sure humans have tried to find a way
to eat it
maybe humanity just has trash taste
vsauce music